it was kind of an instant thing knew
once we locked in together that i had a
partner for life and a teammate
something i could walk to the good times
the bad times with and
that was that was the key one of those
good times for nick jonas and priyanka
chopra parenthood now i'm speechless
over the edge i'm just breathless i
never thought that i'd catch this
[Music]
after announcing they welcomed a little
love bug via surrogate in january a
source tells et the two are enjoying the
roles of mom and dad
priyanka and nick love being new parents
and have been spending a lot of down
time at home it's a special thing the
source adds the two have wanted children
for a while and are so happy it finally
happened priyanka and nick are private
but have let close friends and family
meet their baby the couple echoed that
sentiment when they first shared the
news of their little one's arrival in a
joint statement writing in part quote we
respectfully ask for privacy during this
special time as we focus on our family
my life is very good right now very
excited and like the source says the
whole parent thing has been a long time
coming for nick and pre the pair started
dating in 2016 and got married in 2018.
i think we we settled into
our our roles as husband and wife like
fairly quickly jump to 2019 and a source
told et that nick and priyanka weren't
putting any pressure on themselves to
have kids and were just enjoying married
life and in 2021 priyanka told et the
only baby on her mind was her career i
feel a sense of
contentment and um and i do i feel a
sense of
um
self at the moment with myself
professionally where i am the work that
i'm doing the work that i'm creating and
that's my big baby you know
my my career has been my greatest rock
in my whole life whatever mountains and
valleys that have happened i've always
been able to depend on my work but later
that year a source told et that babies
were on the brain explaining they've
been talking about having children in
their near future i have a lot of faith
in
who my husband is and i know i have a
lot of faith in
the rock that he is for our family and
now that they've officially welcomed
their little one there's no doubt nick
and pre are a pretty good team as
parents here's what the matrix
resurrection star told et about the key
to their marriage just a month before
baby's arrival when the secret was still
under wraps communication having fun
with each other
i think that's the most important the
key is to be able to enjoy each other's
company and just have a great time
then it just it doesn't feel like work
[Music]